who are you the Senate are the guards
read
hey youtubers is Charlie so we finally
got to cease avatar on the flash TV show
but there was a lot of confusion when he
called himself the god of speed so I'm
just going to explain the difference
between God speed in the comics in savat
are and what the TV show is doing with
him so in the TV show you heard him call
himself Savitt are the god of speed in
the comics the reason that Savatage
chose that name for himself is because
that's the Hindu god of motion so he
thinks of himself as a god this Savitt
are also thinks of himself as a god a
lot of people saw him the way his
costume worked in just how badass he was
in thought that he was talking about God
speed now that's not exactly what the TV
show is doing but there are some
similarities so God speed and rebirth is
someone who is so fast that he can be in
two places at once so you can have like
the normal person walking around then
you can have God speed running around
elsewhere murdering other speedsters
so during flash rebirth there was a
storyline where a Speed Force storm
comes and gives a whole bunch of people
powers a whole bunch of random people
all over the city so Barry has to deal
with that he has to Train the ones that
want to use their powers he has to help
the ones that don't want their powers
but here is one of the biggest
differences about God speed he makes for
a much better TV and movie villain than
comic books avatar did so comic books
avatar really just wanted to be one with
the Speed Force that was his only
motivation so he would give speed and
take speed from people like he had a
speed cult that worshipped the Speed
Force with him so saboteur became this
really weird trippy religious story
involving the Speed Force but we know
the big twist was is that Wally West
could give and take speed sabotage could
give and take speed it kind of changed
the way we thought of the Speed Force
itself it was during this Wally West era
that they actually first learned about
the Speed Force itself so they were
starting to use it as a way to tell
really interesting flash stories so
people had different ways of harnessing
it saboteur is a villain as well as like
the stuff that was happening during
flash rebirth is just a way of kind of
reimagining that refreshing the way the
comics treat the Speed Force so when the
way they comment
wally west had like a block in his mind
that stopped him from going faster than
barry allen for a long time because
eventually comic book wally got to be
the fastest flash he was all about this
mental block that they'd erected for
themselves you know for whatever reason
you know whatever hang-ups they had it
stopped them from fully accessing the
speedforce
so Godspeed Savitt are back during the
wally west run they all had like
different ways of harnessing the Speed
Force it was just a way to tell a really
cool story so when both of these
characters were rolled out they were
supposed to be like these uber villains
that were so crazy
over-the-top powerful that there was no
way that Barry or Wally in the case of
sabotage would be able to defeat them
technically Barry Allen wasn't around
when savat R was around in the comics
that was until later but as with most
big stories like this the villains do
something that provides the mechanism
for their downfall like they want too
much power and it just overwhelms them
so that kind of happened with Savitt R
it also kind of happened with Godspeed
so the sabotage storyline was you know
pretty simple arc where he basically
just wants all the speed for himself
eventually Wally finds a way to give
that to him you know the big twist and
he winds up becoming one with the Speed
Force so to speak like that's what he
seeks so while it takes him
faster-faster-faster till you know you
imagined someone like sticking their
finger in a light socket and then just
turning the juice way way up till they
themselves become pure energy so that
was the way that Wally dealt with Savitt
are they brought him back in the comics
later and Barry took care of him during
the first flash rebirth in a really
funny way it was a twist that involved
the negative Speed Force which is
something that we haven't seen on the TV
show yet so just bookmark that for a
future season but as much Mark Waid
sabotage stuff is they're doing this
season like they're doing a Mark Waid
character saboteur but there's a lot of
godspeed flash rebirth stuff happening
the way they used him in that story in
the way they took him down so as you
know in the comics now they brought back
ginger Wally West like the Wally West
from Mark Waid era but there's also the
african-american Kid Flash Wally West so
he ends up help
the flash in flash rebirth takedown
Godspeed but because the flash does not
kill as he says you know no more we're
not doing this anymore he locks him up
it was a much more emotional arc
something I think that would be much
easier to adapt for television like a
much more fully formed character arc for
the villain instead of just give me all
the power or I'll kill you so what
you'll probably see is that Savitt are
on the TV show like there is a person
underneath that armor but in the way
that God speed and a couple other people
during the flash rebirth comic manifests
their costumes from the Speed Force
that's probably what you'll see him do -
he also has powers that people haven't
seen before an interesting twist on the
Speed Force so fast that only people
like the flash people with the Speed
Force can see him that's why he looks
really invisible here it just meant to
be super badass like oh he's so fast
that he's invisible but when you're
talking about him with your friends and
they ask you who is the villain of the
flash season 3 you should say Savitt are
not god speed but if they do ask you
about god speed you can just say they're
borrowing a lot of stuff from god speed
so as the TV show tends to do like it
did with zoom hunter zolomon and Jay
Garrick it kind of blends a lot of stuff
but zoom in the comics is hunter zolomon
zoom on the TV show was hunter zolomon
so that's why i think thats avatar will
still be Savitt are from the comics but
they're borrowing a lot of stuff from
god speed in the comics you know like he
forms his costume out of the Speed Force
he does crazy things that no flash has
been able to do before
even the reverse-flash who supposedly
knows more about the Speed Force than
anybody else the whole reason that he's
called professor zoom in the comics is
because he is a professor of flash and
speed for studies in the 25th century
like they have a school dedicated to
studying the flash in the Speed Force he
eventually became one of the instructors
the real twist of the TV show and this
was also evident during the god speed
run is that Barry kind of creates his
own problems so you know whatever is
going on with Savitt are with dr.
alchemy that happened because of
flashpoint because of something Barry
did when he was being selfish trying to
save his parents even though it meant
changing the timeline so in the comic
godspeed was kind of a consequence of
the stuff that barry was not willing to
do so in a very flash point type twist
godspeed wanted the flash to go back in
time and change the past so that his
brothers murderer would not go free like
Barry's parents were murdered he tried
to go back in time and change that
causes flashpoint is a huge nightmare so
he starts to learn the lesson that there
are some things that you cannot change
there are some bad things that happen
that you just have to learn to accept
God speed of course is a brand new
speedster with a huge ax to grind
against his brothers murderer has not
learned this lesson yet so it's a big
question of what would you do if you
were given the powers of the flash would
you be a hero or would you start
crossing the line being judged jury
executioner so I will say in the comics
the god speed Ark was a much better
character arc but I think that you know
savat R which is like a really
interesting story for the time that it
was published but as with all things the
way they write the Speed Force in the
comics evolves over time so they just
try to do new interesting things with it
sometimes it's cool sometimes it doesn't
work out but if you want to read along
in flash rebirth it's like one of the
best new comics like if you're a flash
fan and you want to read the comics I
just recommend that you start with flash
rebirth don't worry about reading the
old stuff the TV shows only doing a
little bit of stuff from thats avatar
run and I'll point out all the comic
book stuff when they do it on the TV
show but as with god speeds and in the
comics that the way they take him down
with the help of Kid Flash Wally West
I think they'll also try to do something
similar on the TV show because now TV
show Wally West is getting his powers
but the question is is what is he gonna
do with those powers so I think you know
because the TV show wants a more hopeful
spin he will try to help but a big part
of his arc this season is in learning to
be a hero like he doesn't get his powers
and just automatically learn everything
that he needs to learn overnight he has
to learn a lot of the same lessons that
Barry learned the first couple of
seasons and then there's the idea that
Barry has only been the flash for a
little while himself so he's probably
not the best teacher not as good as say
Jay Garrick so hopefully the TV show
will bring back Jay Garrick pretty soon
and he can drop some knowledge bombs on
him cracked cup style like he gave Barry
that speech
kid you can't go back in time every time
you want to you crack the very fabric of
reality every time you try to play God
so a whole bunch of crazy stuff
happening tonight is the killer frost
episode so I'll probably end up doing
like a killer frost video later this
week too just because she's a really
interesting character from the comics I
can't wait to see what they do with her
on the TV show she's going to continue
to be a big part of the show so don't
worry you know whatever ends up
happening with her she'll still be on
the show I think they're just trying to
tell a really interesting Caitlyn arc so
be sure to subscribe to get that video
I'll post it after the episode airs
tonight and there is a new round of the
DC giveaway that's going on right now
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video I'll go ahead and announce the
winner when I post that flash video
tonight but what's going to happen is is
because arrow and legends of tomorrow on
break I'm going to take the opportunity
to do a couple bonus videos so just
restart the giveaway as I post new DC
videos so just look out for that stuff
and if you do want me to start doing
more comic book videos to go along with
some of the TV and movie stuff that I'm
doing just let me know in the comments
you know feel free to make suggestions
what you guys wait for that to post you
can click here to learn all about the
history of cyborg superman in the comics
what the TV show is doing with them and
you can click here for my killer frost
flash trailer thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight